hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen video wie schön dass ihr heute
wieder mit dabei war hat heute geht es
investiere jungpflanzen an soft ich weiß
nicht wie es euch geht aber ich habe so
eine freude in mir auf die neue
gartensaison auf das neue gartenjahr
endlich wieder loszulegen sachen aus zu
sehen erklärt der zeit sich mit dem
thema jungpflanzen an sucht auseinander
zu setzen und in diesem video zeige ich
euch 7 häufige fehler die ich immer
wieder sehen sowohl bei gemüsegarten
anfänger als auch bei fortgeschrittenen
ich hab fast alle dieser fehler am
anfang selber aufgemacht deswegen kannst
gut auf das wird glaube ich ein sehr
spannendes video für euch viel spaß
erfolgs vergesse wenn du ja genau du du
da noch nicht absolviert hast jetzt
wären ziemlich guter zeitpunkt dafür
und auch die klage drücken muss erledigt
super dann können wir loslegen mit punkt
nummer eins der falsche zeitpunkt ich
weiß wie hart das ist ich bin selber
ungeduldige jene frühling weil ich
endlich loslegen will ich habe schon
meinen garten kleine fertig ich weiß
genau was ich waren pflanzen möchte aber
für die meisten gemüse ist es jetzt noch
viel zu früh oder tust du dir deinen
genießen keinen gefallen mit wenn du
jetzt schon vor ziehst weil die dann
viel zu lange im haus waren müssen bevor
sie endlich nach draußen gepflanzt
werden können also halte dich beim
vollziehen immer an die vorgegebenen
zeiten auch wenn er es tat ist ja für
die stehen ja meistens auf dem sand von
tütchen wir drauf ansonsten kannst du
das auch immer im internet nach
wer im garten büchern damit die gemüse
dann eben nicht zu lange im haus warten
bis die wege nun zufrieden in ihrem
kleinen köpfchen die haben da keinen
platz mehr
und das tut ihnen nicht gut wenn du die
zum früh aus den fehler nummer zwei die
licht kein mal ihr glaubt nicht wie oft
ich schon nachrichten bekommen habe von
turin die mir geschrieben haben
ich habe weil sie dem gesetz schon
dreimal aber es kommt kein einziges
pflänzchen viele leute wissen mich dass
ich sagen gibt die licht brauchen um
keimen zu können das gehalt basilikum
dazu hört sellerie und auch salat und
noch einige andere pflanzen die nicht
mit erde bedeckt werden wollen oder
höchstens so hauchdünn
damit sie überhaupt keimen können wenn
du die ganz normal aus bett wie andere
sagen und die fällt mit erde bedeckt da
einfach nichts raus es ist also immer
genug wenn du dich gut foto gemüse aus
selbst informiert wie leg die samen denn
überhaupt mit erde bedeckt werden müssen
und ob sie überhaupt mit erde bedeckt
werden müssen weil wenn du einen bricht
keinem ein zuschauer füllten mit erde
dann wächst da nichts und das ist
einfach super schade und ärgerlich
gerade wenn man nicht weiß woran es
liegt und was denkt oh ich hab keinen
grünen daumen bei mir wächst einfach
nicht meist sind die lösungen auf solche
probleme ganz ganz simpel und es lohnt
sich einfach sich vorher kurz zu
informieren welche ansprüche die
einzelnen gemüse denn überhaupt haben
fehler nummer 3 betrifft alle
kürbisgewächse also melonen zucchini und
natürlich kürbis die mögen es überhaupt
nicht zitiert zu werden wenn du nicht
weißt was zitieren ist das bedeutet dass
mein gemüse pflänzchen erst in einer
schale ausfällt alle zusammen großer
kindergarten und dann sobald ein
bisschen größer sind die einzelnen
diese nimmt und die in einzelne töpfchen
umsetzt so dass jeder genug platz hat um
sich selber in dem topf auszubreiten das
machen wir ja mit vielen gemüsen so zb
mit kohl mit tomaten paprika ich mach
das auch sehr gerne mit salat und sehr
viel den gemüsen mache ich das aber alle
kandidaten aus der familie der
kürbisgewächse mögen das überhaupt nicht
die wollen überhaupt nicht gerne
umgepflanzt werden das bedeutet das wenn
du dir deinen garten pflanzt dass du
dann ganz vorsichtig sein muss beim
pflanzen was bedeutet aber auch dass du
sie nickt pikieren sollte ist die sagen
um immerhin ein großes töpfchen das so
groß ist und dass die pflanzen bis mitte
mai wenn sie dann nach draußen können da
drin genug platz haben
von groß und kräftig zu werden das ist
ganz ganz wichtig fehler nummer mir die
keimfähigkeit jetzt sind wir wieder bei
dem gemüse das nicht wachsen will dann
ist auch wieder bei sellerie ein problem
bei der eine sehr kurze kein fähigkeit
hat das keinen seiner seite und nach
einem jahr schon nicht mehr keinen krieg
ist passt die nagende auch sehr
schwierig und da gibt es einfach so ein
paar gemüse beeren sagt mit sehr
schnellen abläuft das ist nicht bei
allen gemüsen so normalerweise kannst du
denn saatgut ohne probleme mehrere jahre
verwenden natürlich keine fähigkeit
jedes jahr ein stück weit ab aber ich
habe auch schon fünf jahre alte saatgut
verwendet und das war kein problem nur
eben bei so kandidaten wie sellerie
umfasst die nageln
das saatgut nur sehr kurz kein weg ist
da solltest du wirklich vorher einen
keimfähigkeit test machen bevor du wird
da ganz viel aus der ist und wenn wieder
nichts wächst da kannst du einfach auf
den küchenkrepp ein paar samen streuseln
das feucht machen und dann ein paar tage
warten und dann siehst du schon wie
viele der daten geheim sind wenn du
hundert sagen der ist und davon sind
zehn bekommt dann hat
und keine möglichkeit von zehn prozent
was nicht so toll wäre dann weißt du
eben dass du entsprechend mehr saatgut
verwenden musst wenn du dein gemüse dann
erst ist es nur sehr sinnvoll wenn man
gerade wenn man eltern zwar gut
verwendet vorher einen kleinen fähigkeit
test macht so dass man dann keine bösen
überraschungen erlebt oder gerade bei
kraft die nagel gebraucht ja ewig zum
keimen das kann ja wochen dauern bis die
ersten pflänzchen aus der erde
rausschauen
und wenn du dein eigenes saatgut
verwendet hat und du wartest und wartet
und wartet und dann nach acht wochen ist
ja klar dass da nichts kommen wird dann
ist es manchmal schon zu spät und wie
dieses jahr überhaupt noch was die nagen
sehen zu können dass wir einfach viel zu
schade dass ich mir auch schon passiert
deswegen lege ich das wären gerade bei
den beiden kandidaten in keimfähigkeit
test zu machen wenn man alter sack und
verwenden möchte jetzt kommt der größte
fehler überhaupt also hand aufs herz wer
kennt jungpflanzen so ganz dünnen und
gelblich und schwächlich und verteilen
werden war bei mir wachsen so am anfang
und das liegt einfach daran dass die
pflanzen zu wenig licht bekommen und ist
sehr schwer dafür zu sorgen dass die
pflanzen genug licht bekommen wenn es
draußen so kurz nur hell ist selbst an
den südfenster ist meistens um die
jahreszeit noch zu wenig licht um
wirklich kräftige jungpflanzen
anzuziehen deswegen benutze ich seit 34
jahren die pflanzen richter also meine
jungpflanzen station ist ein regal da
hänge ich die energiepflanzen
da einfach über den pflänzchen auf und
so bekommen sie das licht in allen
farben die sie brauchen um kräftig zu
wachsen und vor allem in der menge und
in der länge also der tageslänge man
kann das denn mit zeitschaltuhr
einstellen sodass das 16 stunden brennt
und dann haben die genug licht um
wirklich groß und kräftig zu werden und
das hat so einen riesigen unterschied
gemacht seitdem ich meine jungpflanzen
unter den led licht dann anziehen wenn
sie genauso perfekt wie die männer gerne
einkaufen kann und wachsenden supergut
also das ist eine investition ich weiß
aber das ist eine investition die sich
zumindest bei uns absolut bewährt hat
wenn ihr wollt kann ich euch gerne die
led-lichter unter dem video verlinken
und befasst sich im bund warum wieso
kriegt leuchten ich weiß ich bin es auch
grässlich wirklich einfach wären es die
grenzen ja unterschiedliche fahrer
brauchen unterschiedliche lichtfarben um
wachsen zu können und diese landen sind
eben so konzipiert dass sie genau diese
fahren abwerfen also dass die pflanzen
genau in diesen farben bestrahlen einem
euro 6 ist die temperatur ich hatte bei
der jungpflanzen jahre lagen irgendwo
uns immer am fenster stehen und mich
immer gewundert warum die dann so mit
krieg sind warum die nicht richtig
wachsen warum so lengerich sind warum
die umknicken und ja warum in die herren
aus denen es war eine große enttäuschung
dass leighton nicht so an dem nicht
sondern auch an der temperatur im
wohnzimmer also bei 20 gemütlichen karat
ist einfach zu warm für jungpflanzen ich
habe jetzt im verstehen wir uns nicht
geheizt da haben sie ihre lampen sowie
haben genug licht und es ist relativ
kühl es ist das 16 17 grad warm und das
ist meine erfahrung nach eine serien
temperatur um allen möglichen jungen
pflanzen anzuziehen und fehler hat
nummer 7
ist es die falschen pflanzen vorzuziehen
es gibt gemüse die absolut nicht gerne
vorgezogen werden sie mögen es einfach
nicht umgepflanzt zu werden und damit
meine ich nicht die gurken und die
zucchini vorzuziehen ist sehr sinnvoll
weil man dadurch die saison verlängert
und viel früher ernten kann was ich
damit meine sind vor allem hohe c gegen
wiese wenn du dir vorstellst ohne möhre
mit ihrer langenwaldsee in den töpfchen
gewählt wird und dann um gepflanzt wird
dann kannst du dir vorstellen dass ihr
das nicht unbedingt gut bekommt bei
allen gewesen wo es um die wurst geht
also um die wurzel enten möchtest wie
hören als die nadel schwarzwurzel
haarwurzel und so weit würde ich immer
direkt wählen auch bei rote bete ich
weiß viele leute ziehen rote beete vor
ich habe bessere erfahrungen gemacht
wenn ich dir direkt ins pc generell kann
man sagen dass alle gemüse die direkt
gesät werden diese tortur des um
pflanzen und es in einen kleinen topf
ein gefecht seien nicht durchmachen
müssen und dadurch viel tiefere wurzeln
gehen können das kann man wirklich sehen
das gepflanzte pflänzchen ein
schwächeres und kleinere wurzelsystem
haben als die pflanzen die direkt ins
beet gesät werden und deswegen versuche
ich immer also wenn ich vorher war solch
ein genauso vorziehen oder solches
direkt sehen versuche ich es eben man
direkt ins beet zu sehen weil das eben
residente pflanzen gibt die können viel
besser mit trockenheitsperioden so heiß
dass mir das oft wichtiger ist als diese
ernte verlängerung ich ziehe vor allem
wärmeliebenden pflanzen vor wie tomaten
kürbis paprika auberginen und so weiter
die einfach die saisonverlängerung
brauchen um wirklich ertrag abzuwerfen
aber wann immer es
es ist leichter muse direkt ins beet
wenn du noch keinen plan für einen
gemüsegarten erstellt hast dann kannst
du jetzt hier draufklicken daneben an
habe ich dir die videos verlinkt zur
anbauplanung das eigentlich die wirklich
schritt für schritt wie du deinen
pflanzplan erstellt wir sehen uns
nächste woche wieder macht's gut ist